and that really is the art of marriage
is learning to stop being selfish and
start being a servant and that's not a
degree you can get in college that's not
a major you can take but you can't take
underwater basket-weaving
as well as professional protesting to
make sure that people do not come on
campus with whom you disagree so there's
a balancing act this was a little
research project we did some years ago I
sort of figure out one of the primary
objections of the unchurched those that
have never been the D Church that have
left and so we hired I've got a written
down GfK this research group they called
900,000 people random digital dial had
70,000 conversations boiled it down to a
list of 18 to 44 year olds a thousand
people and male female young white black
old rich young you can take your pick
there's infinite gendered places now
yeah yeah yeah etc bucket everybody
number one same thing the main objection
was intolerance okay that Christianity
is an intolerant religion and then I
wrote it down it then plays itself out
in aid arena so the number two issue as
sexuality number three was politics
number four was morality or hypocrisy
number five with spirituality number six
was gender number seven was scripture or
authority number eight is economics or
greed and number nine is counseling or
relevant to know relevance and what our
research showed massive project there is
only one objection
and that's Christianity's intolerant and
then it plays itself out in different
arenas right and you'll see that blowing
up and trending on social media and such
where it's a political issue or a moral
issue or a spiritual issue or a gender
issue or sexuality issue but ultimately
those are just like eight octagons that
the same fight keeps happening
over the issue of intolerance and that's
the primary objection and from everyone
is that Christian belief structures just
simply intolerant therefore it's
unacceptable and how do you deal with
that criticism because the reality is it
is intolerant of some behaviors of some
practices that are self-destructive but
that doesn't it's it's first up it's not
even comparable to let's say some
religions like Islam which we talked
about a lot you're not laughing hands
off but how do you how do you balance
that again with being authentic saying
well okay this is true these these are
closed Hey
rules these are open-handed rules and
explaining that someone who just
blankets you with intolerant well and I
would say first of all the intolerant is
on the left and the right getting its it
doesn't matter you know who you check
for your political persuasion that it
exists on the left on the right and what
we found is actually the dictionary
definition of tolerance has changed it
used to be you think I'm wrong I think
you're wrong we sort of endure with one
another the dictionary definition is now
changed to we're both right and we
celebrate one another which is what you
see in social media unless I waive every
flag and March and every parade I'm
intolerant right and so you know really
what we have now is a change to where
unless you agree with everyone that
everyone is right and everything is okay
you're a taller and the truth is the God
of the Bible is loving and loving is
more important than tolerating because
tolerance says there's nothing wrong or
needs to change with you love says I
care about you and I want a relationship
but I want my love to exchange you and
the God of the Bible loves you know he
tolerates you he'll take you as you are
but he loves you too much to let you
stay as you are so Christianity is about
change in repentance and God is binary
there's heaven there's hell there's
right there's wrong there's God there's
the devil there's truth there's lies and
God doesn't just look at it all and say
Who am I to judge God feels very
comfortable judging and then the
question becomes does God does a parent
does anyone have the right to say no
right that's wrong right you know and if
you do if your parent you're got kids no
I do not I do not have children all
right I've got five so I got us both
covered a fulsome moment but one of the
first things you learn as a parent is if
you love your kids at some point you
gotta say no right exactly well it
everyone has a line of no I mean we even
said right now with the hashtag blue
right the hashtag we're going everyone
we're going on of course everyone agrees
that sexual abuse is wrong now the
traditionalist Christians have a line
long before that saying here are certain
sexual parameters that we believe to be
appropriate for any relationship for
which you get roundly mocked like Mike
Pence even saying I'm not gonna go out
to dinner alone with a woman everyone
has a no line whether it's I don't go
out to dinner alone with a woman or or
sexually free but take a bit take the
marriage issue right right I mean is it
to people is it three people
they have to be over 18 can they be
under 18 the question is not is there a
line the question is where is it drawn
right and anybody who gets morally
outraged has a line somewhere that they
feel has been crossed right and that can
be political left and all right so the
question is not is a line draw and the
question is who has authority to draw
the line and number two where is the
line to be drawn right that's always the
issue and culturally we keep having this
war that wants to have every line being
pencil yes exactly then you made you
touch in a really good point we've
talked about this it's almost sort of
the female rom-com equivalent to
pornography this myth that well love
means that you love everything about me
and accept me exactly for who I am
completely right now that's just not
reality no one is perfect this moment we
hear that although you're perfect the
way you are which is antithetical to
what we believe is Christians but it's
also just non practical if we actually
believe that no one would ever have a
reason for self-improvement and that's a
big thing I think when young people get
married I see that with a lot of friends
who get married this struggle of women
particularly saying well my husband
would love everything abut just for who
I am and a guy going I love my wife but
this really grates me a little bit um
why do you think that's been allowed to
permeate that this sort of cultural
ethos and it's just accepted well you
know the Bible says something radical
and that's that two people become one
and I'll tell you that takes a bit of
work yes I mean if your life is just
train tracks parallel you have your life
I have my life and I'll see you on
vacation and date night that's you know
that's a little easier but if you're
actually gonna be one you're gonna share
one bed one last name one bank account
worship one God you know start one
family leave one legacy for two people
that are innately selfish and that's
what you find in marriage you think boy
this person I married is selfish and
they're thinking the exact same thing
and you're both right yeah and so it
takes a lot of work to become a servant
and that really is the art of marriage
is learning to stop being selfish and
start being a servant and that's not a
degree you can get in college that's not
a major you can take that's not a minor
you can take you know how to be humble
and serve people
now we don't live in the world that that
holds it up is any sort of value but you
can take underwater basket-weaving as
well as professional protesting to make
sure that people do not come on campus
with whom you disagree
balancing act it is yeah yeah yeah and
so that I mean that's but that's the
world we live in and we live in a world
where you know it is not about humility
it's not about sacrifice it's not about
service and everybody's miserable and my
point is it's not working right which
then creates an interest in is there
transcendent law is there a god who's
behind all of this does God have a way
that's better than our way is it a good
idea to draw some lines and say no
somewhere because if your thing isn't
working maybe your thing isn't right the
final question for and then we have to
go we have a lot of young male viewed a
lot of young female viewers but
particularly a lot of young male viewers
who write us a lot who who feel lost one
thing you've touched on and like you
talked about the media totally fault
this is this is not the mark driscoll
that a lot of people would read about on
the internet um you've really touched on
this false idea of machismo and actual
positive traits of masculinity that we
should reinforce and the difference
there and can you explain that some
people who are watching I I do my best
as a ham and Egger
but I've always when I talk about listen
being a man when I talk about being a
good leader when I talk about being a
good husband that is all inclusive of
being a servant being somebody I mean to
lead to protect is to serve and I feel
like a lot of Christians yourself
included haven't misrepresented here's
the false machismo sort of archetype and
then what a positive male role model
would be what would you say to young men
out there well that's a lay up his name
is Jesus man I mean the most influential
person in the history of the world more
books written about more songs sung to
more lifes devoted toward anyone who has
lived in the history of the world and so
you're looking at the most significant
person is a young male who was a virgin
I mean just that in and of itself I mean
he's in his early 30s and he's a virgin
so today we'd add that to the list of
miracles you know but if you're a dude
who's looking for a role model God
became a man he went through the puberty
years he went through the teen years he
went through the 20-something years all
of his friends were getting married he
stayed single and he wasn't wasting his
time he wasn't a was Jesus strong
absolutely strongest person who's lived
in the history of the world was he
truthful most truthful person who's
lived in history the world did he have
healthy relationships with women some of
his closest friends
Mary and Martha were single women that
he had very close friendly relationships
with but they were not immoral they were
not sexual they were not inappropriate
and jesus knows how to give a punch he
knows how to take a punch and so you
know for me it's like if a young guy
can't just sort of see the obvious that
the Bible is about Jesus and if you're
looking for a role model use the same
one who's been working for thousands of
years there is no better there is no
better option there is no better plan
and and so I think I think Jesus makes
sense for everyone but especially for a
young man that's where you got to start
yeah I think that's a good executor sout
there if you just considered an Aesop
fable as the first step all right that's
let's let's go with that that's a good
jumping-off point also wasn't a big fan
of the temples turned over some tables
so not a weak man I bet you he did his
deadlift sir at least rectals I was told
Pat Robertson was the strongest man in
the world so not good say you could
dress 1,400 pounds but I know that those
numbers can be confused as weird and
there's a pulley involved all right if
you liked this video subscribe hit the
notification bell or if you want to
continue to enjoy free content support
us at ladder with credit com /mo club
where you get the full nightly show an
hour every day free along with all of
our friends content if not you don't
wanna do any of those things you're
probably just here you're watching me
seething you came here to hate watch
that being said the internet was created
for people like you